GILAD GOLAN: Hello,
and good morning,
or good evening, wherever or
whenever you're watching this.
Today, we're excited to
share with you a new product
announcement that has
been years in the making.
My name is Gilad Golan.
And I'm an Engineering
Director in GCP security,
working in
confidential computing.
With me today is Nelly Porter,
the Lead Product Manager
for confidential computing.
Later, we'll be joined by
Morgan Akers, Director of Data
Protection at JPMorgan Chase.
So Nelly, let's start
from the beginning.
What is the data
protection problem
our customers are facing today?
NELLY PORTER: Thank you, Golan.
Really, really great to
have you here with me today.
So data protection problem
is very important problem
for customers.
And in all this time,
they had and understood
how to deal with this problem.
The data customers collected
was on their data centers.
And they know who
accessing this data.
They had really good physical
perimeter across this data.
They can control, not only
access, but also policy that
can be applied to this data.
And they knew that they
are responsible to protect
this data.
So no big news there everything
is familiar and expected.
Moving forward, with
exabytes of data
that our customers
collected, it's
becoming more and more difficult
to keep it on premises.
So they're definitely
looking forward
to utilize cloud power
to process this data.
But then the situation
and security assurances
become a little more fuzzier
and more difficult to maintain,
because sensitive data
is located not only
in one place that they have
full control over, on premises,
but also on different
public clouds.
And what they understand
that they have now,
shared responsibility
for protecting this data.
So not only they are in
control, but also they
need to share this
responsibility and control
with cloud providers.
So the situation becoming
a little more complex.
And as a result of that,
there is multiple questions
and challenges
that our customers
started to come up with
and trying to address.
And if I will summarize
what I hear loud and clear
from my customers,
there are concerns
around very basic topics like,
I have plenty of sensitive data,
I need to bring it to the
cloud, how I will protect it?
And it's not only about data.
They develop significant
amount of IP.
And their application
and algorithms
have to be protected as well.
So how I will do that?
How will I stay compliant
with all regulations,
and all other
rules, and auditors,
requirements that they
have to deal with?
Because it was a little
bit easier when I control,
end-to-end, all my protected
data and all my sensitive data.
But now, when I am
moving this to the cloud,
it's become more challenging.
But it's not only
difficulties, it's
also ability to open a
new, very exciting use
cases that were not possible
before, for example,
the use case of collaboration.
How I will collaborate
with so many companies
that I want to and
have to result in need
to share my sensitive
data and control over
that, with all of that?
Because some of them may
be even my competitors.
And I am not fully trusting
them with my sensitive data.
How would I be able to
process it together with them
and take advantage of the
results of this collaboration?
And also very, very important
question for all our customers,
they are custodians of the
data with their own clients
and their own users.
And they want to do
their task and job right.
They want to protect
their data end-to-end.
So Gilad, with all
of those challenges,
is there any magic solution that
you would be able to offer us?
GILAD GOLAN: In fact,
Nelly, yes we do.
So we, at Google, believe
that the protection
of sensitive data is paramount.
And encryption is
a good mechanism
to accomplish this goal.
We supported, for years,
encryption in transit,
when our customers ingest the
data to bring it to the cloud.
We also supported
encryption at rest,
for data stored in the
cloud across all services.
Encrypted data in transit
and at rest is great.
But it is not sufficient.
Customers bring the data
to GCP for a reason.
They want to index it.
They want it queried.
They want to train
on it or infer
on the data for
their specific needs.
So to complete the data
protection lifecycle,
you would like to be
able to protect data
when it's being processed.
Confidential computing
is a new model
that aims to close this gap.
Confidential computing means
encrypted data in memory
while processing it.
So with confidential
computing, customers
get encryption in use,
in addition to encryption
at rest and in transit.
So Nelly, let's
get to the point.
What are we announcing today?
NELLY PORTER: Yes, Gilad.
We will announce our
creation right away.
But give me a few more
seconds to have some fun.
Let us dream a little bit.
What if with
whatever we're going
to announce, literally right
after, this single, beautiful
checkbox, you, my
dear customers,
you would be able to encrypt
all your workloads that you run
previously, and,
again, enjoyed so much,
and make them confidential,
simply transform them
into confidential environments?
What if you don't need to
pay significant performance
and latency tax of doing
this transformation?
And what if, for
some of you who have
to provide audit reports to go
to your internal and external
auditors, you will be
able to do it very easily?
All of that about your
workloads, what if all of that
will become reality?
And it's exactly what we
want to announce today.
After some really
serious work that we've
done, together with our
partners, AMD, we, today,
announcing confidential
VM on N2D series that
powered by second generation
AMD EPYC processors in beta.
So Gilad, tell us what is that?
What is confidential
VMs all about?
GILAD GOLAN: So what
is confidential VM?
Key thing to remember, It's
just like a regular VM.
Customers can run any workload
that they usually run in VMs.
And by clicking a
single checkbox,
they will transform their
VMs into confidential VMs.
When they do that, all memory
pages off the confidential VM
are encrypted.
So you may rightly ask,
if they're encrypted,
how does the CPU process them?
So data is encrypted
in memory and is
decrypted when it's fetched
from memory to the CPU chip.
And what about the
encryption keys?
The keys are generated
in hardware on the CPU.
They're ephemeral.
They're not persisted anywhere
and cannot be extracted from
the CPU chip by anyone,
including Google.
Each VM memory is encrypted
by a unique key to that VM.
And confidential VMs can
scale to meet your needs,
up to 224 virtual CPUs and
896 gigabyte bandwidth.
So finally, customers can
protect the data end-to-end,
from data in transit,
to data at rest,
and finally, to data in use.
NELLY PORTER: Yes, Gilad.
The way how you describe
the key protection
is very important
for confidential VM.
The ability for
us to use hardware
generated keys which
it not extractable
is very, very nice property.
It means nobody,
including Google or AMD,
would be able to
get access to that.
Any other security
capability and [? strat ?]
[? medication ?] ideas that
you believe we will provide
to our customers with
confidential VMs?
GILAD GOLAN: Well,
as the name implies,
it simply adds confidentiality
while processing data.
That means the hypervisor,
administrators, neighbors,
and malicious devices
cannot snoop your data while
it's in memory.
As a multi-tenant
cloud provider,
isolation has always
been a critical component
of our infrastructure.
Now, with confidential
computing,
this isolation is getting
cryptographically reinforced.
Nelly, can we see a demo
of confidential VMs?
NELLY PORTER: I would love
to show the demo, Gilad.
Thank you so much for asking.
So the first demo that
we will have today
is to demonstrate to our
customers, our viewers,
how easy it is to
create confidential VM.
And as we promised, initially,
it will be simple checkbox.
And you will be
able to transition
your normal, usual VM
to confidential VM.
Let me show you
how it can be done.
So first, you come into
a usual GCP console.
And you give the name
for confidential VM.
And you will find a new
checkbox, literally checkbox,
the will explain that by
clicking this checkbox,
your configuration will
be set for your VM.
And all what you would need
to do is simply say Create.
And that's it.
And your confidential
VM is up and running.
And to prove to you that
it's confidential VM,
let me as a Sage to this VM.
And show it, to use it,
it's running on AMD server
with secure, encrypted
virtualization enabled.
It, indeed, means
all your memory
is going to be
encrypted, when it
will process via code or data.
The second demo that I want to
show you is slightly different.
As you remember,
we were discussing
performance latency and
performance and latency tax.
So I want to demonstrate
you that, based
on what we've done so far and
old testing and benchmarks
we've done, we've seen that we
reached the envelope that we
were putting on ourselves,
not more than 10%
performance degradation.
So we've seen, even, the
results on some of benchmarks
that we've done
together with AMD teams
that we are somewhere
around 2% to 6%,
even better than we
actually put on ourselves.
But every single
customer need to check.
Please check your own workload
and your own performance
benchmarks to see where you are.
But let me show you
this quick demo.
And the demo is showing
you very interesting race.
We will have two VMs that will
start in the same-- almost
the same time.
Non-confidential VM will
come a little bit later
than confidential VM.
But to show you how these two
will perform, first of all,
let's show you that on the
right side of your screen,
you will have confidential,
left side is non-confidential.
And we will use SysBench,
the performance tool,
to validate memory access.
Memory access is
very important way
for us to check how
confidential VM will perform
compared non-confidential.
And because we're measuring
throughput, as you can see,
comparable is great.
And the bigger number is better.
We've done memory read.
Now, we will do memory write.
And let's see how these
two VMs will perform.
And as you can see,
both of those VMs,
confidential and non, are
performing very comparable.
So we didn't see too
much degradation.
But as I said, please validate
your performance results
on your specific workloads,
and let us know where you are.
GILAD GOLAN: Our announcement
of confidential VMs,
today, is just the first step.
We believe that confidential
computing will, and should,
be part of every
enterprise cloud point.
Realizing this ambitious
goal requires collaboration
across the entire industry,
both cloud providers,
hardware manufacturers,
and software vendors
working together
to define standards
and advanced technology.
This is why Google
was among the founding
members of the Confidential
Computing Consortium
operating under the umbrella
of the Linux Foundation.
Together with other key players,
like Microsoft, Intel, AMD,
ARM, Alibaba, IBM,
and many others,
we are working together to
advance confidential computing.
And now I'd like to hear
the perspective of a cloud
customer.
I'd like introduce Morgan
from JPMorgan Chase.
NELLY PORTER: Gilad, I want to
add one more interesting tip.
Morgan Akers that will
join us right away
is also part of Confidential
Computing Consortium.
He is representing
customer voice
in this multi-industry
consortium.
So it'll be very interesting
to hear from Morgan
how he was doing and what is
learning he had from working
with our original pre-build.
Morgan, now it's you.
MORGAN AKERS: Thank
you very much, Nelly.
I appreciate the
introduction, here.
My name is Morgan Akers,
as Nelly mentioned.
I am a director in the
cybersecurity space
inside of JPMC,
and specifically,
in the Data Management and
Protection organization.
If you look at JPMC,
it's one of the oldest
financial institutions
in the world.
They work across the geographies
into a global company,
multiple financial
sectors, customers
ranging from consumer banking,
to corporate services,
to government services, to
asset wealth management.
So really, they run the gamut
in terms of financial sectors.
Additionally, we have a wide
swath of both employees,
in terms of different types of
roles, as well as customers.
And so when I think about
managing and protecting
our data as a mission for data
management and protection,
it's really, how do we enable
data to be managed correctly
and succinctly across
the firm seamlessly
and without expertise.
What I mean by this is
as a user of the data,
you should not have
to know, explicitly,
what to do with this data.
The system should
manage it for you.
You shouldn't have
to be expected
to understand that this
dataset is this sensitivity,
and I know how to actually
manage that policy.
You shouldn't rely
on tribal knowledge.
This should be something
the system handles for you.
And when you think about that
seamless and frictionless
experience of
managing data, that
is, really, the pillar
that we build on
in terms of maintaining
the chain of trust
between our users,
and our services,
and how to use that data.
Now, data management
and protection
is, really, effectively,
three different pillars,
in terms of how we actually
think about our architecture.
The first one is classification.
Classification is, really, the
simplest piece of understanding
what kind of data you're
dealing with, who generated it,
what kind of data it
is, sensitivity level,
is it business impacting?
Is it critical data?
As well as, what
type of data is it?
Is it programmatically
generated by a service?
Is it hand-authored, like
an email, or something
that's a Word document?
And how is it used?
And where is it coming from?
So with that classification
of that data,
with as fine grain of
classification as we can get,
we move to how we do our
policy decision engines.
Now, for every piece of data
based on the classification,
we want to create a policy that
says, given this type of data
and who is using it,
what I should do,
that's the decision aspect.
And we really want to do it from
both a build-time perspective
as well as a runtime.
And what I mean by that
is that it's not just
what I'm programmatically
building my system in terms
of managing the data as I
build my developer toolkits
and my systems across the
financial institution, but also
runtime, for that
real-time decision process,
where an influx of data comes.
You need to be able to make
those decisions on the fly
to apply that policy.
Once that policy is
applied and a decision
is made, you move to data
healing and enforcement, which
is, essentially,
what do I do now?
Is the data encrypted?
Do you make it readable by that
individual or that service?
Is it editable by that
reader or service?
Can you use a token?
Do you need to decrypt it?
Those are the aspects of what
I would consider data handling
and enforcement.
So these three things,
together, form the backbone
of what we think about for
data management and protection.
Now, when we look at
Confidential Compute
as an environment, as what
I would consider an area
to grow and think
about strategically,
it's still somewhat
in its infancy.
So our approach to
confidential computing
is what do we think we can use
it for that would inform us
of a decision, and how
do we, then, incorporate
in our strategy?
So when we're looking at
our Confidential Compute
environment, one of the
things that we came up with
was there is typical models
for user authentication.
But it's not as strong in terms
of a standard model for what
I would call instance
or host identity
models of identification,
especially when
you're dealing with multiple
routers and multiple systems.
And we thought this
was ideal for something
that maybe a Confidential
Compute could solve for.
So what we'd think about is
user and instance identity
is foundational to us securing
sensitive data, who you are,
who you're working on behalf
of, and where it's coming from
is part of that
classification aspect,
as well as where should go to.
If we build what I call a chain
of trust inside of Confidential
Compute, we can do,
effectively, this mapping
that says, all right, service
A can talk to service B.
And the two together will build
that informational system that
understands what we should do.
Now, when I look at
how we manage this,
there is the
customer managed key
that the bank informs us of.
And that, actually,
is what we use
to create the authentication
request, who does what,
and how they actually
talk to the systems.
And that Confidential
Compute system
is where we're
managing that mapping.
So effectively, that
managing of the mapping
is in the node of
Confidential Compute.
It's a user, the
application, or the service,
and the resource that's running
the application service.
And we can use it to both
audit the chains that we make,
as well as the union
of whether you should
grant that handshake or not.
Now, when we think
about this, this
is a general pattern
of discovery.
And you can see by the
big boxes and arrows
that this is very much
a high level pattern.
And it doesn't describe anything
in intimate detail here.
But what we really were
trying to figure out
was if I create this
service to instance mapping
in a Confidential Compute,
how would that work?
Well, general principles are
that the service A and service
B want to actually
talk to each other.
And so service A would actually
go to our Confidential Compute
system and say, all right,
give me a handshake or a token
and authenticate that
I am this service,
and I'm an implementation
of this service,
and I want to talk to service
B. The covetous computing
node would actually take the
mapping and say, OK, service A,
you are actually cleared
to talk to service B.
And here's a one time token to
use, with a time limit on it.
So we effectively
put a TTL on it.
So it's very short lived.
Give that back to service
A. Service A presents
it to service B. Service B then
presents it back to our trusted
system in our confidential
computing system,
and it verified that
the handshake is real.
And it let the two
decrypt the request.
And it's authenticated.
What we've done is we've
moved the authentication
of this information
about the services
away from being done inside
of service A or service
B. It's actually being
done in a third system,
and that's Confidential
Compute, that mappings done.
And service A and
service B can concentrate
on what they're supposed
to be good at, which is
their processing information.
That reduces the
overall threat matrix
in terms of what service
A and service B can do,
because the mapping and that
verification of credentials
is being done inside a
Confidential Compute.
And as a pattern, this
is interesting to us,
because what it
does is it leverages
a lot of the key
infrastructures with services.
But also it takes
advantage of the idea
that Confidential Compute is a
protected and close environment
that can manage this
mapping securely.
So as I mentioned,
that previous pattern,
that's just a general
use case that we
were thinking of an opportunity
of Confidential Compute.
There's additional
things that we
think could be used
for in the future.
Secret storage is one
of the key ones, right.
Managing keys, securing
those keys in its system,
it's just a generally natural
fit for confidential computing.
The second one is a trust
and integrity chain.
The previous example
demonstrated a chain of trust
with service and
instance mapping.
But that can
actually be expanded
to integrity chains of who
changes the data over time
and what that
information has happened.
Or maybe you have a
trusted vendor relationship
across a dataset.
And you want to understand
where that went to.
That chain and that
management could actually
be stored in terms of
Confidential Compute.
Another one is a
machine identity.
Now, we were talking
about instance identity
and authentication.
But when I say machine
identity is actually
putting the materials
on the box themselves.
Typically, that's done
with certificates.
But what if we actually used
Confidential Compute to manage
the certificates and the
resources of those systems,
and there is, effectively,
checking points.
That confidential
computing system
could be the one that manages
certificates and identities
for those.
Post-processing audit/log data,
now, audit data, log data,
generally, they're only as good
as the data that's in them.
And you typically need them to
be readable and parsable to be
able to make the
most of it, creating
those events, understanding
what happened to the chain.
But with that, you
have clear text data
that could pose a
danger and a threat.
If we're able to put that
data in clear, effectively,
confidential computing systems,
they can post-process that
data, get the data--
maybe trigger those
events in a secure way,
and then dispose of
that clear text data.
And actually, you're
focusing all the processing
in Confidential Compute.
And then lastly, is what we
call a trusted enclave for data
transforms.
But really, it's just a secure
environment for aggregating
data, multiple
datasets that you want
to put together and
generate queries,
searchable indexes,
and something as simple
as even machine learning.
If you want to apply machine
learning or other type
of algorithms to data,
typically, those algorithms
need to operate on the
data in their natural form.
If you can actually put that
into a confidential computing
environment that can
actually do that processing,
and you just worry about
the output coming through,
and then dispose
of the data that's
inside that confidential
computing node.
NELLY PORTER: Thank you,
everyone for watching
our show and our announcement.
GILAD GOLAN: So to summarize,
confidential computing
is an industry-wide effort
critical for securing
sensitive workloads.
We're focusing on hardware-based
encryption for data in use,
with the goal of enabling it
for any workload of any size.
Our goal is to
offer our customers
a no-compromise solution.
The security you need without
giving up on usability,
performance, and scale.
Thank you all for joining us
today for this presentation.